Військовий побут по-німецьки: чим годують
і яке вбрання закуповують для солдатів Бундесверу?
Українська армія активно реформується, прагнучи досягти стандартів НАТО.
А ось в яких умовах служать німецькі вояки:
У такій сірій картонній коробці німецький військовослужбовець
отримує свій сухий пайок - індивідуальний раціон харчування.
Він призначений для одного солдата протягом однієї доби у польових умовах,
коли немає можливості отримати гарячу їжу з польової кухні.
Є 12 варіантів сухих пайків, які відрізняються основними стравами.
У кожному наборі основних страв дві.
Приміром, горохове рагу з м’ясом та локшина з фаршем.
Або тушкована сочевиця з м’ясом і так званий мисливський горщик -
локшина з фрикадельками та єгерським соусом.
Є й вегетаріанські пайки і такі, що не містять, приміром, свинини.
Крім того, у кожному наборі - тверде печиво,
яке ще називають "броньовані диски",
хліб житній нарізний, що зберігається у герметичній бляшанці,
сіль, перець, жувальна гумка, шоколад,
порошок для фруктового напою, джеми, розчинна кава,
чай, цукор, а ще так званий забілювач для кави -  сухе знежирене молоко,
освіжаюча серветка, таблетки для знезараження води та сірники.
З таким сухим пайком німецький солдат за день споживає понад три тисячі калорій.
. Термін придатності - близько 3 років залежно від погодних умов.
Коштує такий їстівний набір бундесверівця близько 20 євро.
Ось так шиють і тестують форму та взуття для бундесверівців
Армійські боти занурюють у воду на 6 годин і спеціальний механізм імітує ходу.
Всередині має бути сухо.
А так тестують матеріал на водостійкість.
Не промокнути в зливу під час завдання для солдата надзвичайно важливо.
Це вже готова куртка.
Чи витримає вона такий напір у душі?
Тестувальник розстібує верхній одяг.
Випробування пройшло вдало. Всередині солдат буде сухим.
А це тест матеріалу для шкарпеток на вогнестійкість
та підошв взуття на витривалість.
В інтернеті польову куртку можна придбати від 70 євро і вище,
штани -  від 45 євро,
ремінь з текстилю - 17, а ось такий польовий капелюх - 6 євро.
Жінок у Німеччині почали набирати до Бундесверу
відносно недавно - у 2001 році.
На сьогодні в лавах німецьких збройних сил кожен десятий - жінка.
Минулого року для вагітних солдаток навіть розробили спеціальну форму.
До цього на великих термінах вагітності жінки переходили на цивільний одяг.
За статистикою, вагітніють під час проходження військової служби
близько двох відсотків від 20 тисяч жінок, які числяться у Бундесвері.
Бундесвер перейшов на контрактну основу 8 років тому,
коли був скасований обов'язковий призов на військову службу.
Відтоді німецькому війську бракує новобранців.
Кілька років тому для підвищення привабливості армійської служби
Бундесвер відкрив такий собі шоурум у самому центрі Берліна.
Німецька армія усіма силами намагається презентувати себе
як привабливого роботодавця.
Навіть зняли серіал під назвою "Рекрути" про будні новобранців Бундесверу.
На його зйомки Міноборони ФРН витратило понад півтора мільйона євро,
а на рекламу Бундесверу в інтернеті та на вуличні плакати - ще шість мільйонів.
Це спричинило критику в ЗМІ
і серед пацифістськи налаштованих депутатів Бундестагу.
Новобранців приваблюють не лише зарплатами від двох тисяч євро на місяць.
Міноборони ФРН також переконує, що можна
вдало поєднувати службу в армії і родину.
Догляд за дітьми - важливий аспект для тих, хто починає кар’єру у війську.
Тож Бундесвер вже відкрив власні дитсадки і запевняє:
наша перевага - надійність.
Адже Бундесвер - це роботодавець, який ніколи не збанкрутує.